medrad lawmakers care more about illegal
aliens
a protester holding a banner reading
immigrants built America took the air
out of Trump's speech for about five
minutes but the president largely
avoided attacking minority in immigrant
leaders by name a practice his opponents
had labeled racist instead Trump doubled
down on criticism of the majority
African American city of Baltimore the
homicide rate in Baltimore
is significantly higher than El Salvador
Honduras Guatemala I believe it's higher
than Afghanistan thousands of supporters
had lined up for hours to attend the
rally he's only saying the truth and I
don't know how that's racist to say a
place is trashing he's not racist at all
he's just merely pointing out problems
that exist in our society and we're just
gonna have to correct Trump pointed to
the declining number of border arrests
as a product of his hardline policies
despite criticism of his
administration's detention of children
in squalid conditions Trump lauded his
crackdown at the border and the numbers
are way down you'll see that way way
down Democrat lawmakers care more about
illegal aliens than they care about
their own constituents they put foreign
citizens before American citizens we're
not going to do that the last few days
have seen the Democratic presidential
candidates in the spotlight in
back-to-back televised debates with
Trump attacking their performance
polling shows Democratic frontrunner Joe
Biden leads Trump by 8 points in Ohio at
this early stage of the election season
they vote for any Democrat in 2020 as a
vote for the rise of radical socialism
and the destruction of our great our
beautiful our wonderful American dream
we're not going to let our country ever
go down
route of socialism the trunk campaign
sees a high o is a must-win State in
2020 this bellwether state has in fact
picked the presidential winner
nationally going on for more than 50
years and so we will hear much more
about Ohio as the battleground between
Trump and the Democratic nominee Heidi
Joe Castro al Jazeera Cincinnati Ohio